FEMALE SPEAKER: Hello everybody,
and welcome to a
talk by Peter Samuelson
about his new
institute at USC, the--
I'll let him tell you all
about that, both his
personality and the things that
he's devoted his life to.
And I'll let him tell
you about that.
So, Peter--
PETER SAMUELSON: Thank you
and good afternoon.
I have to first tell you--
I have to say something about
the experience for me of being
in the Googleplex.
In 1984, the Olympics came to
Los Angeles, California.
It was also the year that I
was part of a production
company, a film production
company called Interscope.
And we decided that it was time
that there should be a
film set on a college campus
that wasn't all about the
jocks but that was
about the nerds.
And so we developed a script.
It started off being called
"Brains," and it ended up
being called "Revenge of the
Nerds." And for all of these
decades since, people have said,
you're the father of the
nerds and things of that kind.
And I just want to say, if
that's what I am, as father of
the nerds, I salute this-- the
Temple Mount of nerdosity.
Clearly, this company,
these people, are the
revenge of the nerds.
So I'm honored to be here.
I thought I'd give you a little
bit of background and
then tell you about the Media
Institute for Social Change at
USC, which is my new obsession
and the one that
we're here to discuss.
But I don't think it's possible
to really pitch it to
you, to tell you about it, until
I give you a little bit
of background.
So I grew up in London.
I never did get rid of the
accent, I think because I'm
probably half-deaf or I've got
cloth ears or something.
I was the first kid in my family
to ever go to college.
I got myself into Cambridge
on a scholarship.
I got a bachelor's.
I got a master's.
And then I came out of
Cambridge, and there was no
work of any description
anywhere visible
in the United Kingdom.
So the first job I actually
got was working as an
interpreter.
I had managed to learn medieval
French as well as
medieval English.
So when a film company that
was about to make a Steve
McQueen film in France decided
they needed someone to be an
interpreter, I actually did not
tell them that the kind of
French that I spoke was
medieval French.
And I spent the next several
months making up words for
things that they didn't know
about yet in medieval times.
So I did that, and I worked on
a series of other American
films in Europe-- "The
Return of the Pink
Panther" and so forth.
And I was a lousy interpreter.
I always used to say what I
thought people meant as
opposed to what they actually
said, which was not popular
with people paying me.
So I got promoted.
And I became a production
assistant.
You know, the guy who makes
the tea or the coffee.
And then I got promoted and
promoted and promoted, and I
became a production manager.
But still, it was really
challenging at the time, not
dissimilar to now where there's
very little work for
young people here.
In the UK and in Europe
at that time
there was almost nothing.
And then, one of my wonderful
Americans said, you know, you
might want to come out
to Los Angeles.
And you could work for us.
And we could give you maybe
a year contract.
So I did.
And I found myself literally in
an office at the corner of
Hollywood and Vine, which I
suppose was a Temple Mount of
its own in the sense
of Hollywood.
And I started as a production
manager.
I couldn't get into the union,
so I had to promote myself to
be a producer.
And I started off as a line
producer, which is the person
who organizes somebody
else's film.
And then I managed to get a
film financed, I thought--
the first one that
I would ever have
produced with a credit.
It was called "A Man, a Woman
and a Bank." And we were going
to make it in Vancouver.
And I had financed it with money
from dozens or hundreds
of doctors and dentists
in Canada.
And just before we were about
to start shooting, I got a
phone call from the lawyer in
Toronto, who said, I don't
quite know how to tell
you this, but
they've changed the law.
And all of your doctors and
dentists will not be investing
in your film.
And I said, well, they
can't do that.
It's unconstitutional.
The can't retroactive--
isn't it grandfather--
no, that's America.
This is Canada, said the man.
So I had no money to
make this film.
But I did have people
building the sets.
I had a crew in Vancouver.
So I didn't really
know what to do.
I came back down
to Los Angeles.
I didn't tell anybody that
we had the problem.
And I read an article in the
newspaper about a young man
called Ted Field.
And it said that he had just
turned 25, he had inherited a
great deal of money, he was the
heir to the Marshall Field
family, and he was interested
in motion
pictures and motor racing--
two things that I was
quite interested in.
So I wrote him a letter.
We didn't know where to say it,
but the newspaper article
said he was a student of
philosophy at Pomona College.
So that's where we delivered
the letter.
And Ted phoned me.
We had lunch.
He said, what are you doing that
I could be involved in?
I said, well, I'm actually
in a crisis.
And he said, what do you need?
I said, I need half of three
and a half million dollars.
And he said, OK.
Let me read the script.
I happened to have it with
me, and I gave it to
him across the table.
And he steamed in.
And two days later a lawyer
phoned me and said, where
would you like this
check delivered?
And that's how we
made that film.
So Ted and I ran Interscope
for six, seven years.
Then I was bought out.
And I've been an independent
producer ever since.
"Tom & Viv," "Wilde," "Arlington
Road--" I think
I've made 23 films
in 25 years.
That is one whole
side of my life.
But the epiphany, the thing that
changed my life, is not
making films.
Of the films I've made, half a
dozen of them, I think, are
quite good.
Some of the others we don't talk
about or even dare name.
Some of them made money.
Some of them didn't
make money.
But what changed my life was
nothing to do with film.
My cousin met a child, an
11-year-old little boy, who
was seriously ill-- dying, in
fact-- in a hospital in
London, and asked him, what
would make you happy?
And the little boy, whose
name was Sean,
said, oh, that's easy.
I want to go to Disneyland--
which, considering that he was
in a hospital bed, in a very
bad way, with all sorts
of equipment and
nursing and so forth--
My cousin and I said, well, if
that's what he wants, that's
what we should do.
We flew him and his mom
to Los Angeles.
And the first thing
was, we couldn't
get them into a hotel.
So everybody-- the cousin, the
mom, and the little boy moved
into my apartment on
Wilshire Boulevard.
And for two weeks, we did all
the things that you are not
supposed to do, for sure, with
a seriously ill child.
We took him to Disneyland and
Knott's Berry Farm and on the
beach and we borrowed Ted
Field's helicopter and we went
up in that.
And he had a fine old time.
And he went home with his mom
with his Mickey Mouse ears and
all his other souvenirs.
That was not the epiphany.
The epiphany, which I think has
changed my life and a lot
for the better, is that--
Sean went back to London.
And he died.
And it was both sad
and not sad.
Everybody knew he was going
to die, including Sean.
And we had talked about it
at the dinner table.
I had a lunch with a man called
Steve [? Ulaky ?]
from HBO.
He was the commissioning
editor.
And there I sat in the Regency
Club, and I tried to sell him
some project.
I don't remember what it was,
and he didn't buy it anyway.
And halfway through the lunch he
said, what else is new and
exciting in your life?
And I said, well, I just had
this extraordinary experience.
And I told him the story of
little Sean and the visit.
And Steve, the man
from HBO, cried.
He wept at the lunch table.
It was in one sense incredibly
embarrassing.
He was embarrassed, I was
embarrassed, the waiter was
embarrassed.
The whole thing was a complete
catastrophe.
After we--
I don't remember how
I said goodbye.
I hope I hugged him.
And he went off to the men's
room to sort of recover.
I remember going down in the
elevator and thinking, I'm a
film producer.
We sell stories.
I just told someone a story.
It had this effect.
Maybe I could tell some other
people the story and it would
have an effect on them, too.
So I did.
I called a meeting of a dozen
people in the Interscope
boardroom after work.
And I just stood there.
And I said, look, this
is what we just did.
This is what happened.
This is why I think
it had value.
Maybe, who knows, we
could do it again.
There must be a lot of other
sick kids in the world.
And maybe we could help them.
Maybe we could make
them happy.
It wasn't any more complicated
than that.
And that, really, was the first
meeting or what became
the Starlight Children's
Foundation.
So here we are.
It's 30 years later.
I won't tell you any
of the middle.
But what Starlight was in
the last fiscal year--
we raised a little
over $60 million.
We served 5.2 million children
and their moms and dads and
their brothers and
their sisters.
We have around 50 offices across
the United States,
Canada, Australia and New
Zealand, and the UK.
It's become a very big deal.
It's one of the leading children
charities providing
psychosocial services to kids
who could use a little help in
being happier when they're under
great stress because of
their medical condition.
So the clock moves forwards.
And in the early '90s, I got
myself a meeting with Steven
Spielberg, who didn't
know me from Adam.
But one of things you learn
is you can meet
anyone in the world.
You just phone up
and ask nicely.
And mostly, you can get
in and see them.
So I did.
And I was told, you
have 15 minutes.
Don't leave your collateral
material with Mr. Spielberg.
Leave it out here.
And please be gone
in 15 minutes.
So I went in, and I was deer
in the headlights.
I was still there
an hour later.
I was there two hours later.
I was there two and a
half hours later.
And at the end of it,
Steven said, what do
you want me to do?
And I said, be the chairman
of a new nonprofit.
What will we call
it, said Steven.
And I thought, OK.
Starlight--
Starbright.
I said, you'll be the
Starbright Children's something.
And he said, OK.
I'll do it.
And what will we do?
And I said, we need to
provide an online--
remember, the word online, a
little early to say that in
the early '90s--
I said, I can see that we are
going to link kids together
when they can't get out
of a hospital bed.
And if we do that, I
believe that they
will help each other.
And we could also provide
distractive entertainment and
education and so forth.
And Steven said, OK.
And as I was leaving, he said,
now, if I'm going to be the
chairman, I probably should
donate some money.
What do you think
I should give?
And I said, honestly, I just
don't think I was put on the
earth to tell Steven Spielberg,
of all people, what
he should give to charity.
And he said, no, no.
I can always say no.
Just give me a number.
And I said, no I'm not going
to give you a number.
He said, you can't leave unless
you give me a number.
So I said, I, well I--
have you ever have one of those
moments where you sort
of feel as though you're
not in your body?
And I felt as I was sort of
up here watching my mouth.
And my mouth said, two, two and
a half million dollars?
And there was a silence.
And I saw his mouth from
up here say, OK.
And I came out.
And I actually went and
hid behind a tree
in the parking lot.
And I called my wife.
And I said, I think
I just had a
meeting with Steven Spielberg.
I think I was in there
two and a half hours.
And I think he just donated
two and a half million
dollars, and he's going
to be the chairman.
But I think I may have
hallucinated.
And there was a silence.
And my wife said, do you think
you're safe to drive?
Maybe I should come
and get you.
So in 1995, Norman Schwarzkopf,
Steven
Spielberg, and I--
at Digital World that June
we pressed a button.
And we turned on, I kid you
not, the world's first
avatar-based, continuously
running social network.
In 1995, we had kids sitting
on the east coast video
conferencing with kids
on the west coast.
You navigated--
you first chose an avatar.
And then you navigated it.
It was before there
was a mouse.
So you could only navigate
in right angles.
It was kind of an Etch-A-Sketch
kind of an
experience.
Because to go diagonally you
had to do it in a zigzag.
And they received distractive
entertainment.
If two avatars bumped in one of
the three worlds, it opened
up the video conference
and you chatted.
We had to--
it was about a $50-million
investment by all sorts of
different companies, in
cash and in kind.
It enabled children who couldn't
get out of a hospital
bed to do so.
It obviously evolved.
It's never been turned
off since.
Starbright World runs 24/7.
It is supervised by trained
people who are paid, staff
people, in Los Angeles.
And when Los Angeles goes
home, they hand off.
It's been like Houston
mission control.
They hand it off to
Sydney, Australia.
And they run it through the
night, their day, and then
they give it back in their
evening, which is our morning.
So that was number two.
Starlight, Starbright, you
begin to see the pattern.
Number three was that in 1999
I got incredibly angry--
pissed off, actually--
at what goes on with foster
kids in America.
I just couldn't get
my head around it.
How can we know best practice
but we don't do it in 3/4 of
the country?
How can we, according to UNICEF,
rank one from dead
last in the first world
when measured by
the welfare of children?
How can we understand best
practice but we don't do it?
Nobody that I know
hates children.
Why would we marginalize half
a million foster kids with
appalling outcome stats, where
one in two ends up homeless
within two years of aging out?
Where, at best, they end up
in minimum-wage jobs.
They never go to college.
3% of foster youth ever get
a college education.
So I got a little bit angry.
And sometimes it's
good to be angry.
And I formed the third nonprofit
with Sherry Quirk in
Washington.
I said, where are all lobbyists
in this city?
They all say, K street,
northwest.
That's where all the office
buildings are.
And I say, great.
That's where we'll
open our office.
And we will bang away.
And we will get laws enacted,
enforced, we'll get budgets
put in place, and we will
be the lobbyists and the
advocates for foster kids
because God knows they've got
nobody else.
They will never march.
They are children.
You've never read an op-ed.
And in fact, because of all the
secrecy laws, you've never
seen the face of a foster
child in the newspaper.
So if nobody understands what's
going on, and they
cannot self-advocate,
well then why would
anything ever change?
So for a decade, First Star
worked top down, not
grassroots.
Top down, drive using
embarrassment in the press,
give school grades
by jurisdiction--
there are 2,200 jurisdictions.
Give them A through F and
embarrass the ones with an F.
We had a headline in the Boston
Globe a couple of years
ago-- we flunked.
That's what you want.
You want them saying-- you want
the legislators to say,
how can this be?
We have an F?
And up the road they
get A-minus?
What are we doing wrong?
Let's go to emulate them.
So First Star--
top down for a decade.
And then one of my board
members, Kathleen Reardon,
who's a professor at USC in
the business school--
she said, so, I've been
studying this.
Everybody agrees that the most
difficult kids to place are
foster kids because whereas you
can find a foster home,
perhaps, for a little girl of
eight, if it's a 6 foot 1"
16-year-old boy there's a whole
higher hurdle to jump.
So those kids end up in what
used to be called group homes.
But group homes are so terrible
that they got renamed
congregate care, which didn't
make them any better.
But we do that in America.
We change the name because we
think somehow that will
miraculously improve things.
So these group homes are mostly
run by private entities
under government contract.
They have 100 beds, they have 75
beds, they have 200 beds--
they are warehousing.
They are, in many cases-- not
all, there are few good ones--
but almost all of them
are dreadful.
And they guarantee that kids
will come out when they turn
18, normally, and will go
straight into unemployment,
welfare, criminality, or
whatever it is that they've
learned in there.
And as I said, half
of them end up
homeless within two years.
So Kathleen said, so, I've
had a better idea, maybe.
I don't know.
It's like a huge idea.
But I can't really--
I don't know what
I've got here.
Tell me what you think, if we
put one of these group homes
somewhere better.
And I said, well, where would
you put it, Kathleen?
And she said, well, what would
you have if you put it on the
campus of a four-year
university?
What if you put a group home,
call it a boarding school, for
foster youth in ninth, 10th,
11th, and 12th grade smack in
the middle of a four-year
university campus?
I said, well, the first thing
you'd have is let's say 25,000
undergraduate potential big
brothers and big sisters.
The second thing that you would
have would be you've got
every kind of expert.
How many psychiatrists
do need?
Do you want some
social workers?
How about people who
measure things?
What about some educators?
We have a whole school
of education.
I said, I have to believe
it's been done.
So we got a couple
of grad students.
We looked all around
the world, not just
in the United States.
No one had ever done that.
So we did it.
I went and got a meeting with
the chancellor of UCLA.
And I said, hello.
You don't know me but
we have this idea.
And he said, have you read
my 10-year plan?
And I said, no Chancellor
Block.
I'm an idiot.
I haven't read your
10-year plan.
It would've been a
really good idea.
He said, I'll read you
two sentences.
He takes it out and he
runs his finger down.
And he says, UCLA, as a
taxpayer-funded public
university, will strive in every
way possible to build
affirmative pathways to
post-secondary education for
young people, none of whose
family members have ever
previously had that advantage.
He says, check one.
And he runs his finger down and
he says, UCLA will try in
every way possible to use all
of its prodigious academic
skills to be the most excellent
neighbor to the
community surrounding
it, the community
of greater Los Angeles.
He says, check.
He says, do you think
you could raise the
money for this thing?
I said, I'm clueless.
I don't know.
But we can try.
He says, OK.
Well, if you raise the
money, we'll do it.
So we did raise the money.
And we did do it.
So our first academy
started two years
ago on the UCLA campus.
We now have three because a year
later we set up George
Washington University in DC.
And we also are at the
University of Rhode Island.
We're about to add a major
university in Connecticut and
another major university
in Illinois.
Just before Christmas,
I was in Washington.
I met with the Department of
Education, the Department of
Health and Human Services, I
met with the staffers of 10
members of Congress.
I met a senator.
This is a very, very big idea.
We don't know what percentage
of these kids we
will get into college.
But it will be one heck of a lot
more than 3%, which is the
benchmark if we don't
intervene.
So you get the pattern--
Starlight, Starbright,
First Star.
I couldn't think of anything
to call I See Tonight.
So I did something different.
One of the things that has
served me really well in my
life is if I'm kind of scared of
something, I sort of take a
deep breath and do it.
And I decided I was scared
of homeless people.
So I did 62 interviews with
homeless people while riding
my bicycle on weekends.
The first thing I found out is
I thought they were all men.
And they're not all men.
They are 60% male, 40% female.
I thought they were all
middle-aged men.
No, actually 18% are under
the age of 18.
Sorry, 15% are under
There's children
sleeping rough.
I thought when I asked
them, where do you
go to bed at night?
I thought they'd all say,
I go to the shelter.
I go to the mission.
I go somewhere like that,
the Salvation Army.
So it turns out just in greater
Los Angeles, the
county, we have 65,000,
in the most recent
census, homeless people.
But we only have about 14,000
beds in shelters.
So whichever way you cut it, we
have tens of thousands of
men and women and children
sleeping in the scrubland off
the freeway, behind
the pillar--
you know where they are.
They're where you see them.
You think there are no women and
children because they hide
better, I discovered.
The epiphany--
I believe in epiphanies--
for me was that an old lady,
when I asked here, where do
you sleep at night, my dear?
She said, come on,
I'll show you.
She takes me behind some bushes
behind a pillar off of
the 405 freeway.
And there is a huge
cardboard box.
And on the side of the cardboard
box, which is her
home, it says Sub-Zero.
And I thought, OK.
That's the epiphany.
Because I got the refrigerator,
she got the
cardboard box.
What the hell is this?
This is America.
We have money.
So my first thought was,
I'll build shelters.
But when you run the math, it's
about $50,000 per bed
that you generate.
And that's just to build it.
So 100 beds, $5 million
kind of math.
So I said, OK.
50,000 times, say,
60,000 people.
Oh, wait a minute.
That's $3 billion.
I have no clue how you
raise $3 billion.
So I said, OK.
Never daunted.
What's the best we can
do with $500 a head?
What could we build with $500?
So I tried to draw a thing.
I knew in the daytime,
it would have wheels.
You would push it around.
And then at night, you
would park it.
You would open it up somehow.
And it would turn into a cot
with a tent over it and some
doors and windows and
off the ground.
I tried to design this thing.
I have the spatial ability
of a newt.
So I thought, well, who
knows how to do this?
You see, film producers
actually don't
know how to do anything.
All we know how to do is
hire people who know
vastly better than us.
So I went to Pasadena Art Center
College of Design.
I went to Dean [? Korshek ?]
and I said, have you ever done
like a nonprofit design pro--
No, we haven't.
And I said, well, couldn't
we have a prize?
I'll put up a little
bit of prize money.
He said, what you want
to call this thing?
Because I described it.
And I said, I don't know.
We can call it whatever
you like.
Anyway, by the end of the
meeting we had decided it was
called an EDAR.
E-D-A-R. Because everyone
deserves a roof.
So we had the competition.
I'd been working with Eric
Lindeman and Jason Zasa, who
were in the competition.
Ever since, we got a
fabrication house.
We built, I think, 50
in the first batch.
We gave them away on Skid Row.
We got the Rand Institute
to do an efficacy study.
And we're up to-- this
is only in the
last, say, three years--
we're up to about 300 people
who sleep in them now every
night in greater Los Angeles.
I like to say, on a scale of 10,
if 10 is an apartment with
a nice warm bed and if
zero is a cardboard
box on a rainy night--
so we're a five.
It's nowhere near as good
as the apartment.
But it's one helluva lot better
than the cardboard box.
And three weeks ago, end
of last year, we
got the patent issued.
So we actually now are patent
holders, which is great
because it means that we can
hopefully sell them to other
for-profit entities.
And then we can take the money
and give them, obviously, for
free to yet more homeless
people.
So I had this really happy life
until April of last year.
I made my films.
I raised my family.
And I did Starlight and
Starbright and First Star and
EDAR very happily.
I thought, I'll do this another
10, 15 years and then
I'll hang it up and I'll read
the "New York Times."
At which point I got a phone
call from USC, from the
chairman of film, a man
called Michael Taylor.
And he said, come have
some lunch with me.
So we had some lunch, which led
to more meetings with him,
which led to meeting the dean.
And by the end of all of this,
we had decided that there was
no good reason why there would
not be, and every good reason
why there should be, a new
institute at USC, within the
film school, which we have
called the Media Institute for
Social Change.
And faced with running this
thing as part of a team--
I'm the managing director--
I had to make a decision
whether I was going to
continue to produce
films or was I
actually going to do this.
And I decided that the
opportunity was so enormous
that, really, I have to do it.
So the Media Institute
for Social
Change has five programs.
And I suppose at its core it's
why I'm standing here in front
of you in the revenge of
the nerds of Google.
So the first thing is, we are
already teaching, and we want
to teach much more, media
for social change.
What is it?
How do you do it?
How do you audiovisually create
a moment of empathy?
And while the person, the
audience member, is moved in
their heart, how do you give
them an action point so that
they will vote, donate,
volunteer, recycle, whatever
it is that you want
them to do?
Absolutely chip away,
raise awareness,
it's not without value.
But really the highest value
is you want people to do
something that they weren't
previously doing or weren't
doing enough.
So we're teaching it.
We're teaching undergraduate
courses.
Were teaching graduate
And as we raise more money
we will do more and
more and more courses.
The goal is to send forth
a legion, a battalion of
prosocial media makers into
the world as we graduate
students who with all, for some
of them, or with part of
their time will affirmatively
struggle to make, using their
audiovisual skills that they've
learned, the world
into a better place.
The timing is particularly
fortunate.
Number one, you may have noticed
there are quite a lot
of problems in the world.
Some of them are intractable.
Some of them are susceptible
to study, to science.
Others require a massive
change of thought.
They require people to think
differently and to prioritize
differently.
You can try and do that
at the point of a gun.
You can try and do it by
persuading people with science.
But really, really, the way
that people are moved is
emotionally.
And you don't do that--
you can scare the hell out
of them with a gun.
But you are unlikely to affect
a lifelong change when you're
no longer pointing the gun.
The camera is a lot more
powerful in this business of
changing hearts and minds than
either a gun or logical
persuasion.
Because what we are doing is
creating a moment of emotion.
We are then suggesting, after
all due research, an action
step, and we are inviting people
to join the cause.
Now, who is our audience?
This is where it gets
really exciting.
Who is the Google audience and
who is the audience for motion
picture, television, interactive
video games, both
in a box and massive
multiplayer, and all the
online stuff?
We take a very broad view
of what media may be.
It's all of those things.
It's documentary, it's fiction,
it's long form, it's
short form.
We're kind of platform agnostic
because God knows the
platform changes every
10 minutes.
Who is the audience?
Well increasingly, the rising
wedge is Gen Y. What do we
know about Generation Y-- young
people aged currently
between, say, 15 and
the late 20s?
The answer is it's the most
prosocial generation of young
Americans since 1937.
They are more volunteering, more
donating, than either of
the two prior generations
of young Americans--
their parents' generation,
their grandparents'
generation.
You actually have to go back
to the Great Depression to
find another generation that
really said, oh, dear.
This world is really fragile.
I'd better do something
about it.
I better do my bit.
I better pay something
back in.
I can't just take and
take and take.
I need to exert myself and make
my world a better place.
We're all in this
thing together.
Then they had the Second World
War, where a lot of young
people fought and saw
terrible sights.
And they came back and that
generation have been
incredibly philanthropic
ever since.
The present generation, Gen Y,
is more philanthropic, more
caring even than them, when
measured by volunteering.
The interesting thing is--
young people start volunteering
in high school
because you can't go to
college without it.
You need to put it on
your on your resume.
But the interesting thing is,
even when they get into
college and after college, they
carry on volunteering
because they realize, hey, that
made me feel really good.
So our audience--
we do not have to teach them
that the world is a fragile
place and that everyone needs
to help to make it better.
We also do not need to teach
young people to pick up any
kind of a video camera or their
PDA with a video camera
in it and point it.
They even sometimes
know how to edit.
What we do have to do is to
teach them to be excellent
storytellers.
We have to go back to that
basic equation--
audiovisually create empathy
and then couple it with the
action step.
Now the action step is easier
said than done.
The first thing is
don't be evil.
Do no harm.
Very much aware of where
I'm standing and
what's written on the--
I actually didn't see
it on this trip.
I don't know which wall it's
written on, the don't be evil.
But I salute that.
The first thing you have to do
if you want to be prosocial
media maker is you'd better do a
bit of research and work out
what the truth is.
You have to validate what it is
you're persuading people to
do because God forbid that you
would have them do something
that would make things worse.
You can't make a film about
autism without understanding
something, a lot,
about autism.
Because it's the bully pulpit.
People will think you must be an
expert because you made the
film, or you made
the webisode, or
whatever it may be.
So don't be evil.
Do your research.
So one component of what we're
teaching undergraduate and
grad students is how to get your
issue right, where to go
and find the experts.
This is where it's brilliant
being on a college campus
because we've got
all the experts.
Walk 300 yards and there's an
expert in whatever it may be.
So mission one, already
underway, is teach
undergraduate and grad students
how to be excellent,
motivated, proficient prosocial
media makers.
It's that Venn diagram between
media generation and make the
world a better place.
It's the lozenge in the middle
that we're teaching.
The second thing, and this is
why I'm banging around raising
money at the moment, is we
want to do scholarships.
We think that media is the
great transformer.
It is the great leap from the
way things are to the
way they can be.
So what we want to start
doing, increasingly, is
offering scholarships and other
student support where
basically we're saying to
underprivileged kids-- whether
they're inner city, whether
they are from the Native
American Navajo reservation,
wherever they may be where
things are not right, things are
not just, things are not
good enough, there is poverty,
there is deprivation, there is
inadequate opportunity.
We're saying to them, OK.
Come to USC.
We will put you through
these courses.
You will come out at the other
end as a proficient,
prosocial, qualified,
trained media maker.
And your part of the bargain,
the grand bargain, is that you
need to go back where
you come from--
perhaps not with
all your time.
You go have a bang-up
commercial career.
But with a significant
proportion of your caring and
your time, you need to know that
you have an affirmative
moral obligation to make your
people have better lives.
Go back where you came from,
a little bit like Teach for
America, and lift up
your community.
So that's the second thing,
is student support.
The third thing is everything
you can imagine that an
institute should do--
and that other institutes,
but not on this
subject, in fact do.
What is the history of
prosocial media?
First of all, what is
Lenny Riefenstahl, excellent
documentarian--
clearly not prosocial, made her
films entirely for Hitler.
I don't think we would say
she was prosocial.
What about Michael Moore?
Michael Moore makes films that
a lot of us agree with.
But he never puts the other
side of the argument in.
Do you need to do that or don't
you need to do that?
What is fair in the context?
Where is the line between
polemic, or political, and
truth in media?
What is your obligation?
Do you have one?
I'm not suggesting any
answers to that.
But it is an issue that needs
to be endlessly debated.
And you may have noticed that
universities are good at
debating things.
It's something that has to be
front of mind when you, in
this case, don't put pen to
paper but put recording media
into camera.
So, the history.
Another whole area with this
huge and largely untapped is,
what is efficacy?
If it doesn't work, why do we
waste time, treasure, and
caring to do it?
When does it work?
There's all sorts of anecdotal
evidence that things work.
And sometimes it's
been measured.
We know that when the Felicity
Huffman character in the
prime-time soap "Desperate
Housewives--" that they gave
her breast cancer
in the story.
And we know that mammograms in
America rose 30% in the month
following that first
broadcast.
And we know that if you run
those numbers out, several or
many thousands of American women
did not die of breast
cancer because of early
diagnosis, which they got
because they were watching,
quote unquote, "a silly soap
opera," which is what reminded
them they needed
to go and get tested.
So we know that these
examples exist.
I would suggest to you there are
other examples where they
didn't move the needle at all.
"Kony 2012--" so you can
quibble with content.
Kony, at the time the film came
out in April last year,
hadn't actually been in Uganda
for three years.
So what were we really
advocating?
That the Ugandan army should go
to a different country to
capture him?
Not sure.
Furthermore, the Ugandan army
itself has child soldiers.
So were we really advocating
that one lot of child soldiers
should go and catch and
liberate another
lot of child soldiers?
Not sure.
You can quibble about content.
But even if you just assume
that it was completely
accurate, what good did it do?
Is there actually one child
soldier in East Africa who
isn't a child soldier today
as a result of the most
successful viral video in the
history of the world--
100 million hits
in eight days?
Enormous success.
I said to the managing
director or executive
director-- whatever he is--
of the organization that made it
that regardless of what he
did for Africa, I felt that his
gift to the world was that
he said to young videographers,
young
filmmakers, you know, you
actually could aspire to 100
million views for your video.
And that might be.
If you get it right, if you do
your research, if you do it
empathetically, you actually
could change the world.
So I think that the great gift
of Invisible Children and of
"Kony 2012" is perhaps nothing
to do with Africa.
It has to do with what I'm
talking about, which is that a
camera is more powerful
than a sword or a gun.
But we need to get it right.
And we need to do more
prosocial media.
The other stuff that
institutes do are
seminars and colloquia.
Our fourth thing that we're
doing is to really try to
introduce causes that
could use a little
help to media makers--
whether they're students
or professionals--
who could give them that help.
There are too many secret causes
for good where, simply,
they don't know--
nobody out there knows what
the orphan cause may be.
So that has to do with
introducing the foundation
that is trying to find a cure
for a disease to the show
runner of a television series
which could feature them,
which would then drive people
through the end credits or the
website of the--
I did a thing last night for
Starlight where we approached
"The Bachelor." And you would
think that the ABC show "The
Bachelor--" not very
philanthropic.
They actually said, oh, God.
We would love to feature
Starlight.
We've had a deluge, this
morning, of support and tweets
and so forth.
Because last night two of
Starlight's special kids went
with on a date to
Magic Mountain.
And they were on "The
Bachelor." And
it got great ratings.
We can laugh about it.
And we can say, well wouldn't
it be better to raise money
from foundations that give
to causes that support
seriously ill kids?
Yes, absolutely.
We do all of that too.
But actually, "The Bachelor" got
seen by, what, 1,000 times
more people than we would
otherwise be able to approach
in any given month?
It's a lot.
It's powerful.
It's the megaphone.
So then the last thing that
we're working on, and we
haven't done it yet, is we want
to do a media awards.
We think that in the run up to
the Academy Awards-- which, as
you well know, they're
next month.
Every year they're
in February.
And there are all those
other awards shows on
the way to the Oscars.
There's the Golden Globes and
the National Board of Review
and all the rest of it.
We think that there should
be the prosocial awards.
We think that a university is
who should sponsor it, with
corporate help.
In the end, maybe not
year one, we think
it should be televised.
And we're talking about
the same categories.
We're first of all talking
about motion picture,
television, interactive,
and online.
And secondly, we're talking
about actor, actress, creative
team, production team, maybe
lifetime achievement, maybe a
corporate award.
But everything measured
rigorously by prosocial intent
and prosocial efficacy.
So we're pulling that together
at the moment.
My life has completely been
turned upside down.
I was a film producer.
I'm now a recovering
film producer.
I'm the managing director
of the Media Institute.
I consider that I'm honored
and privileged, really, to
have been given this great
big bully pulpit of USC.
USC is absolutely the
place to do this.
One of the reasons why I'm
standing here is that
Stanford, by act of God,
has no film school.
If it did, none of you would
be here because you would
already be involved somehow with
them if you cared about
these issues.
The USC film school is either
coequally the best or the best
film school in the world.
It is certainly, indubitably,
the one that is the most
related to Hollywood.
And our graduates are
everywhere, across the
broadest possible span of
professional, motion picture,
television, interactive, video
games, online, and all the
rest of it.
The reason why I've thrown
over what was, as my wife
points out, a lot--
a really viable career--
and that I'm doing this is
it's the first time in my
whole life that someone has
enabled me to do, in one room,
at one time, the things
that I care about.
I care about young people and
their future in the world.
I care about media
and its power.
And I care about making the
world a better place.
For the very first time,
these things have
been brought together.
I got a taste of it when Jeff
Skoll asked me to go on the
original three-person board
of Participant Media.
And Jeff has made an enormous
success of that company.
He has not only made the world
a better place, but he has
done it in the context of
actually earning money and
breaking even and doing
better than that.
So there is evidence
that this works.
I remember early in the life
of that company, sitting in
front of a major studio
president who said, I know you
are in good faith.
Let me explain the motion
picture industry to you.
People have miserable
little lives.
They are largely unhappy.
They go to a multiplex, and they
pay $12 or so to sit in
the dark for two hours.
And we make them happy.
And when they come out after
two hours, they go back to
their miserable, shitty lives.
And we have their money.
That is the motion
picture industry.
And I said, what about
catharsis, Aristotle's
poetics, Shakespeare's
tragedy.
He says, yeah.
But not now.
Motion pictures are an
escapist medium.
No one will ever go to see
something with a message.
I believed then that
he was wrong.
It was easier to believe it then
because Jeff Skoll had
the staying power to prove
that it was wrong.
I do believe that we can teach
a legion of young people.
Think of the leverage.
If we turn out 200, 300,
400 students a year.
If they each go off and in their
career make 100 or 1,000
pieces of output, and if each of
those is seen by 100,000 or
a million or 10 or 100 million
people, this is an enormously
powerful initiative.
So we'll go to a Q and A.
I hope I haven't bent
your ear too long.
I'm watching the clock.
My life at the moment is
passionately believing that we
can do something incredibly
important here with MISC, the
Media Institute for
Social Change.
I do believe that here at
Google, there are people who
have personally taken part in
transformation or change.
I would immodestly say to you
that the difference between
Google's effect on the world--
which has been radical,
dramatic, a multiplier, and
for the good--
and what we are doing in MISC
is as just started.
And Google's been doing
it longer and
in a different direction.
But I believe that in the end
of the end, there will be
these media institutes in film
schools around the world.
We will welcome them
copying us.
I think we are inventing and
others will emulate.
The world is a fractured
and broken place.
But winning hearts and minds
is how we defeat
the sense of otherness.
It is how we draw
people together
to find common solutions.
It is how we affect leadership
and compromise.
That is what we are trying
to do with cameras
of one kind or another.
I'm very grateful for your time
in listening to this.
And I hope that there
may be some way--
I brought a pocket full
of business cards.
You, especially those of you who
have participated in one
of the world's greatest IPOs--
should you believe that the
multiplier of media deserves a
bit of help and support,
I'm your man.
If you have ideas on course
work, on partnership
opportunities, whatever,
I would love to
discuss them also.
I'm coming back up
on February 15.
I've actually been asked to show
my film, "Revenge of the
Nerds," at The Hub.
I'm incredibly trepidatious
because A, I haven't seen it
for 20 years.
B, I do know that when we made
it in the mid-'80s, the
computers were the
size of a bus.
I think it was before Kaypro
and Osborne, which was my
introduction to personal
computers.
So God knows what is in it.
I don't even know if
it's funny anymore.
But we're going to show the film
at The Hub the evening of
February 15.
And then I'm going to be that
back up the week of March 5.
We are very eager to work with,
quote unquote, "Silicon
Valley." You guys
need content.
You've got the hardware
and the software.
In the area of content, I think
we can try and create
that Venn diagram of what does
good as well as what is
commercial.
We can do what is noble and
honorable as well as what
makes a buck.
So thank you very much.
And if there are any questions,
there's a
microphone over there.
And I'm sure I don't know
any of the answers.
But we can punt.
AUDIENCE: As I sit here, I'm
just entranced with what
you've said.
And I have a lot of questions.
But the first one is, if you
were to construct a list of
the top three things that you
would want from a group like
this, what would those be?
What are you looking for?
PETER SAMUELSON: One--
and I'll just be transparent
and honest--
one, we are eight months
into our institute.
We need money.
Because the more money, the more
scholarships, the more
programs, the more research,
and so forth, which then
self-replicate.
So we are, in my view, still
priming the pump.
And the currency of acceleration
is money, like
most other things.
Secondly, partnership.
I'm particularly interested in
understanding how technology
can make the world a better
place when you
add into the trifecta--
technology, make the world a
better place, and content.
How do we technologically move
hearts and minds by placing
content within the technology
that has that aspiration?
And then, also, I believe that
measurement is something that
a lot of people here
are very good at.
And I think we're not
necessarily good at
measurement yet.
Psychologists measure all
sorts of human behavior.
Not a lot of that has crossed
the street into the area of
prosocial media to try to
understand whether we are
being efficacious.
A film like "The Blind Side--"
Sandy Bullock took a minuscule
fee, took a year of her life,
and made that film.
Did it to move the needle--
I'm not saying it did
or it didn't--
in race relations and in
understanding the challenges
of kids in the inner city?
What did it cost?
And what was its value
to the world?
And I don't mean
to pick on it.
It was a fine film.
I think we need to measure
this stuff.
And another thing that may be
possible is the Venn diagram
where technology and measurement
overlap.
AUDIENCE: Just to follow on
that and I'll sit down.
When you say partnership, is
it the big world of working
with technology developers to
try and create something
that's in your head?
Or is it more of an ongoing, how
do you disseminate some of
the ideas and finding a platform
by which it can get
out faster?
Or is it both?
PETER SAMUELSON: I
think it's both.
And if I knew exactly what it
was, I wouldn't be standing
here being deliberately
a little vague.
I do believe that we have many
opportunities to take what we
know about content and what
you, for one, know about
technology and also about
the community up here.
And the real excitement is
to say, here we are.
Here is the effect we
would like to have.
What are the technological,
financial, pedagogic, and
educational, generally,
things we can do with
technology-enabled media that
would actually shift that
needle and make the
world better?
Give you one example--
so , politics you may have
noticed, is completely screwed
up in the United States because
there's no middle anymore.
Everything I've ever led, what
the leader is supposed to do
is to find the middle.
Everything worth doing, you
can't please everybody but you
find most common ground
in the middle.
Well, people hate each other
now in Washington.
They won't even sit next
to each other.
How can we use media to
find that middle?
How can we help democracy
to flourish and
thrive using content?
And what is technology's place
as a partner in doing that?
AUDIENCE: Great.
Thank you very much.
PETER SAMUELSON: I want to say
thank you to everybody for
your time and caring a little
bit about this.
I'm going to take an enormous
stack of business cards, and
I'm going to put them
on that podium and
keep a few in my pocket.
If you would like to discuss
this further, one-on-one, I'd
be honored.
And, as I said, I'm back up here
for a couple of days that
include the day after
Valentine's Day.
I have to be in LA for
But the next day, the 15th,
I will be back up here.
And if you'd like to sit down,
have a cup of coffee, and talk
about this further, you are the
revenge of the nerds and
I'd be honored to do that.
Thank you.